hello everyone we are back again
i did not end up taking a nap between
the xbox and screenings press
conferences
it is 5 14 am this one is starting in
about a minute
um i'm very excited to see the world
premiere from
uh edos montreal always
um as well as whatever updates they're
giving to marvel's avengers that is
definitely something i am
i'm interested and curious about as
someone who um did not love that game
uh for context before this show starts i
am watching the dmca free version um of
course
all of my e3 live streams have been
immediately dmcad
so uh oh i need to turn that down
[Music]
probably about there
maybe a little bit louder
that's probably it um so yes this one
will not have
the same music that i think the same
that the main event has virtually anyone
who's streaming it probably will have
the lexus free one running
so that's what this is right now and um
yeah i'm looking forward to it i don't
know how long this one's gonna be i'd be
surprised if the square enix conference
ends up being an hour i don't imagine
they have enough content for that i know
we'll see
like a strange um again very excited
about whatever
a montreal studio has to show um
always interested to see more final
fantasy
that's enough i would love to
they make a lot of great games as it
turns out that's square enix
and yeah i i'm i'm very curious when
they announced today we're gonna be
talking about uh marvel's avengers
oh thank you rory i appreciate that um
if there's anything they can do to get
me interested in that game because yeah
i
uh aside from it like breaking my pc
um i have a good pc but i had to
hard unplug my pc because whenever i
would close that game it wouldn't
actually close in the back end and it
would stop me from
being able to play any other video game
it was not
good and also ran terribly like things
wouldn't load in
or things would just disconnect
basically i was into the premise
so um if there's something that they
they have here that would get me back
into it i am very
open to that assuming that there have
been performance updates
so i'm hoping to see something like that
um yeah joel i'd love to see tomb raider
tomb raider would be awesome
i also agree that it's unlikely conor
just said that too um
yeah more near would also be great but
also seems unlikely
okay you guys let me know if i need to
adjust
any audio here
of course good afternoon everyone
it's matt mercer here and i'm back as
your host
presents they told me today we have a
special e3 edition of the show for you
with new game announcements updates and
exciting news from our studios across
the globe very flashy so let's kick off
with the world premiere of a brand new
game from idos montreal cool
a graphic artist did a great job
beautiful work
i am so proud of you
do you know what a birthright is peter
a lot of people go into space lately huh
gardeners of the galaxy what no rocket
so i let groot fill out the paperwork
damn so we got fined
we appear to be six thousand nine
hundred and six i didn't expect it to be
this
i know we clearly need a plan
[Music]
oh it could be used as a distraction
it seems like it's like it's not a
marvel avengers type right like is this
just a single player
you had one job quill i did exactly what
great teammates i'd love to be following
it's literally in your contract
i made no such
[Music]
in less than commitments cycles all
would be lost the galaxy
cannot be saved we can do this together
i'm into it
i'm sure this is a great license song
that got actually played
[Music]
cool damn i did not expect that
no no of course i will i'll call you
i'll call you
sweet hi my name is olivier senior
producer at idos montreal for the past
few years we've had the privilege
to work what a great subject of marvel's
guardians of the galaxy
and reimagine it into a single player
story driven
third person action adventure game thank
you that's what i love to hang out and
refresh
that's what i love to use something
that's really unique to our game is that
you get to be
peter quill as star-lord you're
constantly in the middle of the action
as you try to lead this band of misfits
but today i'm really really excited to
have all of you join us on this journey
and you'll hear more about the game our
team behind this project
right let's do this it is weird jeffy
the licensing stuff is cosmic
characters got a really soft growing up
as a kid it's really read them enjoyed
them i uh have the opportunity to but it
doesn't look like chris pratt
doesn't actually look like dragons i
went back with the help of bill roseman
the editor
and kind of cherry-picked characters
from marvel's past
but i doubt it was to build a team but
to make it all underdogs
so that the reader would think oh my
gosh how is this team going to survive
and that became the guardians of the
galaxy comic which we loved working on
i remember the first time that the
marvel these games came out
we were showing them the design of the
characters how they would look
and they stayed silent i don't know if
it's a minute but in my head it was a
minute i was like
oh my god like they hate it we realized
how much that marvel and adults montreal
share and have in common and that we
knew
the guardians were in perfect hands
looking at the samples that are kind
enough to show me
i think he's fantastic and absolutely in
the spirit of what these characters are
what makes the gameplay experience
unique to me is
no matter in what phase of the game you
are whether you're an exploration
i wonder if it'll play kind of like the
guardians are constantly around you
and you never feel based on the way it
looks like the guardians will activate
the deadpool game
and make decisions on their own and you
will have to adapt to it you are
literally part of the guardians of the
galaxy the decisions you'll make will
have light-hearted to hunting
repercussions and the game will react to
what you do and say the more no
killing teammates that's who it's
literally in your contract
i made no such commitment
you are playing as star-lord and you're
using your blasters and you're using
your jet boots yeah star-lord i agree
that it looks a lot better than the
avengers game
you can slide and over with nice it's
like vanquished
we're not pirates we're legally
incorporated heroes for hire
gardeners of the galaxy what no
the story is about a group of misfits
the guardians
in our world they've been together for
less than a year
they create something on a small scale
that looks
insignificant and as they progress
through the story they discover that
they created
something really big that threatens the
galaxy there are a lot of
very interesting villains in the marvel
franchise
and when you're starting to truly you
get to get your pick
of which ones will make the best for
this story
that gives us that would be really
exciting to bring in some that are well
known
but some that are also not all that well
known
interpreting it in its own way i think
makes it feel incredibly fresh
and exciting it's not a matter of trying
to replicate the comic
or trying to replicate the film it's
trying to take the medium you're working
in and make the best
that is what it feels like to me this
isn't supposed to be a movie adaptation
or anything like that
and people always get those expected
expectations which can be really
[Music]
complicated
don't
are they gonna play through some of it
is that what this is
ah
it makes like extra 37 units we appear
to be six thousand
why square wanted to do a conference now
we intend to keep our ship peter quill i
know
i know we clearly need a plan what about
selling gamora's crap
what oh come on you've been hoarding
them stupid knick-knacks ever since you
first joined us i mean
don't tell me they ain't worth nothing
quarantine zone was always
golden hour my figurines are not
knick-knacks
team's in trouble then you can't be
bothered to make
i like that i think we should
hear our group for once
you know the only problem with your plan
is that lady hellbender
only buys monsters and you are not a
monster
groot are you really offering to no no
he is not offering that okay it could
work
so groot i guess we could bust him out
after absurd
lady hellbender seeks the monster within
the small
ugly one is clearly the correct choice
he's cruel
sadistic and his soul is filthy and
filled with women he's not wrong i vote
we saw groot
i honestly think lady hellbender will go
forward yeah well
i vote for nothing i also vote for the
creepy little beast
he votes each peter
well rocket's definitely scarier on the
inside he's unstable and vicious and
totally oblivious to the needs of others
okay we uh we get it
all right let's do this
we're not seriously flying into it you
say the weather patterns of second of
nine are tied to the temperament of this
ruler
that's not how women work or whether
i don't like the drax voices though so
far but obviously that could change
adjustment i ever mentioned how much i
hate grain
hellbender's castle isn't even that far
that is not a castle it is an
impregnable fortress
so how do we impregnate it ask peter
let's just get closer i don't know what
this is
this particular area they keep showing
great gameplay i guess we will just find
out i wonder if this is an unedited
sequence
all that's left welcome taco this is
marvel's guardians of the galaxy i think
is the official title
[Music]
right the fact you ain't sure don't vote
so good
whoa that is some really crazy lightning
out there
never seen any feel like you're not
gonna be able to go out there
um well sons of liberty this isn't mcu
this is by definition
not marvel cinematic universe because
oh
style platforming these are going to
drop when you jump on them and you have
to coordinate or something
don't fall it will be fine jet packs
with me
yeah i'd love it if it had movement like
vanquish that would be awesome
oh are they alive cool
it seems like you should have fallen
five of them
everyone okay yeah welcome the mgu you
should have gone to michael
i would be wary uh you know what i
survived freaking half world i think
i've scared us a little bit
it's not alone get ready
what are these things
shoot first questions later drop them
this won't hurt much
[Music]
okay so you do have potty controls like
like um
sometimes so hard to say when watching
combat though because like you want to
know if it feels floaty or
heavy the only settlement i saw when we
were topside
i am in detail fortress dead
that's just great it's a retractable
bridge they use them at the prison i was
in
too bad games must have a [ __ ] ton of
titles
what do you not have time to dawdle in
this jungle i shall hurl the creature
over the chasm so you might activate the
breath i
may activate they are very chatty that's
what i'm saying it's like
they could overdo it that's a lot to
write me down
it'll be fine just curl up in a ball i
think it is because the focus is trying
to make you feel like you are one of the
[Music]
goddesses
i guess that only applies to cats you
sons of dogs
i am not familiar with this wonder if
it'll be like a temperature do its job
remember that fast face fix the bridge
and we'll raise your cup by five percent
i said this on twitter recently but i
found out
um okay deal the telltale
this character will remember that thing
is fake there's actually nothing
tracking anything
it's just text it doesn't track anything
just text up the top to make you feel
like there's a consequence but it's
totally fake
oh guys more cubes
i got it
these creatures
[Music]
interesting
yeah i feel like acting like this is
sort of like that deadpool game is
probably the best call
i feel like that makes sense
like looking at this gameplay doesn't
make me go oh [ __ ] yes you know i'm not
like
fully into it so maybe if you look at it
more as a double a
which is you know garbage ones don't
even really mean anything but mindset
wise
ah that's stuttering
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i feel like i'm getting less into
it the more i'm seeing
but so hard to say
that is definitely my top 10 fortresses
peter aren't you forgetting something
oh right the cage
the point of even getting the flark was
looking like mean business
all right rocket time to put on your
monster face i only got one face quill
are you sure about this peter look at
him
you better have one hell of a sales
pitch
looks like a monster to me i don't know
about that
maybe gamora is right we should try
selling groot instead
this is an affront to democracy i just
think that
we might need rocket on the outside for
this one
yeah we noticed
you want to make that call then you
better not mess this up
you hang tight there bud when the time
comes i'll get you out of there
rock and style if i got it drat
gamora can you help me with this what
why
to guarantee your safety as a leader
honestly though how much of this budget
did they blow on voice acting
is it this chatting all the way through
that's that is wild
no i think yeah when you're playing
through it that would probably be
welcome
um i said before you would feel like a
guardian yourself probably
i think that's the intent
[Music]
so not long before someone else wants to
pull this thing we have 60 clicks from
the fortress i'd say
closer to 75. we got this
all right yeah i went from like stoked
to a bit less stuff
i'm not going to say it looks bad
someone in chat say it looks like dog
[ __ ]
i don't know that i agree with that one
step at a time
um
i'm just not sure now
we'll have to have to play it hey thanks
chris
[Music]
uh they're definitely showing other
games yeah i mean i know that's one
thing that i think squares nailed to
i love uh
revealing a game or announcing a game
and then giving this much information
about it
i respect the many times you didn't need
to i
have to kill you actually showing
gameplay rather than just flashy
trailers which is something that i would
probably
you could run um criticize xbox one
in there
[Music]
so yeah definitely respect to that
game's probably still pretty early
probably 2022 release
wow october 2021
that okay again it it the gameplay did
look pretty early
but that is if that's how it works i
love that
that they announced a game show gameplay
and it's out this year
now we're going to read the best brands
that are being reached
in three years in development first up
relive the classic games in the finals
great and then love that tonight
that's my thing
sweet
[Music]
very cool
that's awesome all through six
that is that's awesome that is a great
call
wonderful because a lot of people don't
play those games
six is fantastic that is that's that's
excellent
we will take that for sure
um welcome pj blastwoods huge fan of
your game
the uh splash screens are totally like
um
persona the way they've animated it in
the red and the black and white
[Music]
nice
[Music]
again another very close release date
people like legend of mine are a lot
up next earth's mightiest heroes
continue their fight to defend the world
in marvel's events i am
interested in crystal dynamics is
excited to share the latest updates with
you
including new mission types and a
growing roster of heroes
avengers secure that super weapon at all
costs
cosmic energy is building up
i'm now thinking that maybe they can't
actually sell me on this game because
even when i'm looking at gameplay
it's beautiful i'm looking at and
thinking
but it won't work
the game was just so broken for me maybe
i should have played it on console which
seems like such a weird thing to say but
literally had to turn my pc off the
point because it would prevent me from
playing any other game
and like yeah falling through floors
bosses being in the wrong area so
they're inaccessible
i will save it very rare that any
mission actually works
you don't understand what that cube is
capable of
nice to have a layout of their content
roman though i know there are people who
are
super into it and had much better
experience
i wonder if this one it says licensed
music has been removed yeah it's not
been replaced
they just took the music out of this
trailer
it definitely affects this stuff when
you're so used to it being there
was that black panther
i applaud your efforts to connect with
your roots
but is a man who has seen
three black panthers fall i
must warn you of a few things many eyes
follow the path you are about to walk
down
that's cool
be honest you just wanted to show off
this suit
it's a cool suit man i wonder how the
kinetic abilities actually work in
gameplay i feel like that's
cool this totally
needs music but
thanks to square for doing it
my uh xbox stream got blocked in some
countries
because of the music
nice yeah
listen i like black panther
oh it's free wow that's actually very
surprising to me
now it's time to give mobile players a
quick look at some of the games
that will be available in the coming
months
good evening 426 our intelligence
reports a new threat to global stability
really
their reach is unlike anything we have
seen before on
asian 47 there was already a puzzle game
you were selected
because of your remarkable skills
execution
must be perfect what does it look like
we will strike from the shadows
and they will never know what hit them
wait doesn't that today
yes good again no music
they're just silent instead
it's such a weird way to watch a
conference
nope not what i thought it was going to
be
you've just muted it
hey everybody how you doing
there we go music came back
it's it's amazing how important it is to
showcase that
that actually looked pretty good for a
mobile game whatever that was
today the team at platinum games is
giving you an exclusive look at the epic
world of babylon's fall
featuring fluid combat powerful weapons
and a unique art style also one of my
favorite studios
platinum absolutely love platinum would
die full platinum
right now i feel like it's arcane and
platinum
for a thousand years it was meant to be
a tower of dreams
but for a thousand more it was seen as a
tower of ruin
[Music]
some concept artists definitely had fun
with all this ice
and the coldest of winds
eventually the tower became a symbol
of unrelenting ammunition
[Applause]
[Music]
sometimes i forget if it's something
someone's told among us
let's find out without further ado
oh my god
[Music]
wow i did not realize that was that long
ago
[Music]
if i'm to die then i'll die for hope
for what little hope there may be
someone that looks sick
[Music]
we get platinum very good at combat
enemies believe only what you see
and you like to end up seeing only what
you believe
[Music]
i feel like a lot of this stuff is too
long but i wonder if um
[Music]
really again i just love platinum um
i wonder if it's just having different
music makes it stand out more
for you but even as someone who now
begins its tale
of both hope and despair definitely will
play that game i'm like
that's a bit long ah very good
you love to see it okay
i met him and he was wonderful
friendly square it's present summit
showcase on squares
well they have already mentioned
[Music]
um
i really do love them
don't mind if i don't check out the next
major entry in the popular
life is strange series true colors the
team at deck 9 is ready to give you a
deeper look at alex chen's psychic power
of empathy
but first here's a look at the
lifestrange remastered collection
wow it feels how long would you like to
speak after five years you're still in
max caulfield
maybe i was still in australia it was
seven years ago eight
what do you remember about us as kids
i think about us as little pirates
running and jumping through arcadia bay
i feel like it's probably my least
popular video game take but um i'm not a
fan of life is strange
not that i think there's anything wrong
with them they just aren't for me
it's just not my kind of game come on
let's dance or
take my picture with your new camera
i felt abandoned
oh good you're here rachel saved my life
she was my angel something happened to
her we have to find her max
i don't really like so they clearly
showed some upgrades in the faces and
stuff
but i don't really feel like max what's
going on because it's such a specific
art style
i don't feel like it's really aged that
badly i discovered i could reverse time
emotionally
whatever's going on between us is
special step back before you regret it
step back before you then i realized i
had a choice
and the power to change everything
i forgot about all the dead women
archaea bay is on the edge of disaster
time to change time whatever happens
i'll always have your back always
hey sure to make a lot of people very
happy it's popular franchise
they've just never been for me really
maya also known as
mxm tune i'm a musician and the singing
voice of alex chen in the upcoming
life is strange true colors i hope you
enjoyed this
official
both life is strange and before the
storm this collection features improved
character animation
lip sync and visuals it does look better
new life into these two beloved games
back in march we also revealed the next
major game in the series
life is strange true colors a small town
supernatural mystery
alex chen must uncover the truth behind
her brother's death
using her psychic power of empathy to
unravel the shocking secrets
of haven springs today we have a first
look at alex's unique power in action
here's game director zach if there is
more um
actual gameplay like that's that's a
reduction i would say
power of empathy is integral to the
story just like something a bit more
action orientated then maybe i'd give it
a shot it impacts
every relationship obviously i like
story driven games decisions she makes
a real big fan of combat freaky and bad
friend i really like
snappy alex has been unable to shut down
her feelings of others
the fear sadness and anger
leading her to believe her power is a
curse
in the wake of gabe's death alex
realizes the only way she can find the
truth
again for anyone just joining me this
should also have music i would think
and the only way to understand is to
feel what he's feeling
i think she's cute also the town is cute
you can use
alex's power to focus on brightly
colored auras
to gain an insight into people's
emotions too
young just too young i don't think this
is very much insights deep in alex's
relationships
and events as here from a scene the
mechanic mainly is like get to see how
people are feeling
you're gonna lose her and it's all i
don't think i'm into this
and that's okay covered a secret that
mac wants to keep hidden from his
long-term girlfriend
and now he is terrified that alex will
reveal it before he can talk to riley
she is the best thing that's ever
happened to me
so please help me out did he get beat up
something happened to him
max telling you a whole lot [ __ ]
listen thanks for telling me the truth
alex but are we
still together are you serious unless
it's music has been removed
i need to get back to work sure alex
will uh
we'll get out of your way
when alex encounters a particularly
strong aura she can reach out to
actively connect with that person's
emotions
this generates a nova a supernatural
flair
that transforms the world around alex
into a reflection of that person's
psyche
hmm that's interesting in this altered
emotionally charged state
alex can experience fragments of
thoughts and memories
together imagine that of their issues
pretty rare though that's sort of
psychonauts
not every emotional crisis can be easily
dealt with
some carry a dangerous even
life-threatening amount of power
he's dead this isn't the studio that
made same cool games really sure
huh no decision is easy and the
consequences will be felt across the
game
this anger could kill her what if
i could just take it away
using alex's powers the only way you can
uncover the truth behind her brother's
death
what would that do to her nice [ __ ]
though what would it do to me
and the whole outfit she's cute she's
super cute that's all i'm saying
should i how far will you go in pursuit
of that truth
the choice is yours
alex's powers look so awesome
but i can't wait to play it with you all
when it comes out on september 10th
don't forget all so good they really are
showing the stuff that's about to come
out
now and if you choose that you'll also
receive the life estranged remastered
collection
and that's it for today make sure to
follow the life is strange social
channels for more
is that it for the whole conference or
is that it for this particular part of
the conference the life of strange part
i think we've covered everything maybe
that they said they were gonna cover but
i don't know
the colors are also very pretty
now we are excited to unveil a brand new
title from square enix japan
oh my god my stomach is rumbling so loud
but the memory of their struggle buried
deep in their hearts
[Music]
i'm here to kill chaos okay
looks like chaos has been waiting for us
hmm i will take whatever this is thank
you
i guess we'll just show ourselves here
i only know one thing that is
[Music]
very devil may cry vibes
[Music]
okay sure chaos is here yeah they can
only squash monsters for so long
i hate doing pest control this is the
shrine of chaos
he's here you just have to hunt him down
yeah it's devil may cry final fantasy i
mean unsurprisingly
in that creative direction no doubt
i i do like that crystal shadow thing
that they keep showing them into it
is this a final fantasy game his name
was garland
you could i would be grateful if you
looked for him
chaos it probably is right or is it
something about the way they revealed it
made me think it was new ip but they
didn't actually say in uitv
and who are you we're here to kill
chaos the prophecy's very own warriors
of light
he always wore such splendid armor
with a helmet that was terrifying to
behold
it's garlic no
i become chaos
there you go
that makes sense so it's kind of both
it is garland that's for sure
interesting so it's sort of a new final
fantasy game
hmm what does soon mean how soon when
suit
i'll leave you with a look at some of
the amazing square enix titles you can
play now
i'm very interested in that
wow just hit me with it i'm gonna drop
plate number seven
they're gonna do what
i wonder no it's fine i'll find out more
information that has like piqued my
interest probably more than anything
else i've seen over e3
it was like the chaos reference
but then not titling its final fantasy
ps5 demo
very cool
whoa that was cool too
there were some ups and downs in here i
think no no of course i will
i'll call you i'll call you some things
that thank you for joining me about that
that i enjoyed i respect the hell out of
them for showing gameplay
rather than just pretty trailers and see
you next time
for um having things really soon
like definitely really appreciate that
so
yeah some things i liked and some things
i didn't like so much
it's all right also appreciate it being
a shoulder conference that that was
40-ish minutes um i think some things
probably could have been a little bit
shorter they probably could have made it
30 minutes and probably been just as
satisfying but
some stuff i was into some stuff i
wasn't into obviously very weird without
the licensed music
i feel like it's probably like a whole
other thing
if you do have music
it makes it pretty weird
[Laughter]
um so that is it for today it is now 6
am i'm going to go
to bed they sh they showed a little bit
of
the spoken but that's about it um am i
gonna do nintendo i think the nintendo
one was at like 2 a.m for me so probably
not
what i'll do is what i literally just in
between these two conferences
is um pick the highlights and make
videos of them rather than streaming the
whole thing i was going to initially but
it's it's just going to make my work day
too awful
so i decided against it so thank you
guys for joining me
i'm going back to sleep an okay
conference overall
an okay conference overall i had i had
an alright time
my stomach is grumbling so loud oh my
gosh
um all right have a good day everyone
[Music]
bye
you